for our series pushing the limits we
meet a blind entrepreneur who's making
rock-climbing accessible to the visually
impaired 22 year old Matthew Shiffrin
invented a simple system using Legos to
help people climb when they can't see
CBS this morning Saturday co-host Dana
Jacobson spent an evening at Central
Rock Gym near Boston to learn how this
system relies on memory and touch Dana
how did he come up with this idea it was
pretty crazy it was sort of a back story
here schefren was born without sight
which prevented him from doing what most
kids do which is build Legos so at 13
with the help of a friend he started
lego for the blind creating instructions
in Braille for Lego sets that work
inspired a collaboration with the Lego
foundation and just last year they
announced a rollout of audio and Braille
building instructions for some of their
kids now taking that love of Legos and
innovation Schifrin is helping the
visually impaired reach new heights you
don't have to rock climb to know yeah
there you go nice it's no easy feat
above your left shoulder you got a good
hold even with perfect vision left foot
but Matthew Schifrin is proof that in
climate generated lack of sight is a
comparable obstacle sighted climber
comes to the wall looks at it and then
is able to really think their process
through even before they get on the wall
and I was thinking you know there's got
to be a way to create a system so that
blind people can feel climbing routes
before they climb them bring your right
foot to left knee kind of step through
that system relies on the caller the
eyes on the ground to mock up the wall
using Legos and each Lego each piece
represents a different type of foothold
that he'll know yeah Shiffrin scholar is
max Hernandez and in a matter of minutes
oh yeah I can see it now not even
kidding now it makes sense he converts
this wall into this map of Legos this is
gonna get
in traversing right senator Shiffrin was
born with a condition that causes
abnormal blood vessel growth in the
retina which creates scarring resulting
in complete blindness he says in many
ways Legos gave him eyes how do Legos
help you see the world around you
they've miniaturized the world because
when blind people touch things touch a
sequential when you build with Lego the
scale is so small and so convenient that
you're able to take in entire buildings
entire city escapes with a single hip
the idea that something that's a child's
toy could open up the world for you I
think it's pretty incredible to some
people it's thrilling a sentiment echoed
by visually impaired climbers Mandy
Curtis and Justin Proctor how have Legos
made you a better climber Mandy Matt
really brought this to life from nowhere
and I joke that he's some kind of wizard
the way that you can take Legos and
really write out a climb in a very
tactile way helps me understand
not even the precision of the shapes of
the holes but the the way the climb is
gonna flow
Justin how about for you I thought no
it's an amazing idea Mego is you can
just come up to the routes and the
routes change often and you can move
from climb to climb without that lag
time Proctor has a degenerative eye
condition which over time caused him to
lose all his vision I like to push the
envelope but I know what my limits are
at the same time and Curtis has site in
only one eye which she describes as
looking through a doors peephole why is
it important that somebody that has a
limitation do a sport like that I think
the thing is like we always think about
disabilities as limit
but the truth is like it's not the
disability that limits the person it's
the world that we live in that limits
people and it's become shiffman's
personal mission to keep paving the way
giving the disabled community more
access I think it's really up to us to
always be energized as disabled people
or just people who think from a
different perspective everyone deserves
the thrill of doing something that they
never thought was possible
Schifrin hopes that this lego system
will be used at the Paralympics and
adapted for other sports like skiing so
that blind skiers can know what to
expect even before they go down a slope
he just never stops thinking he's
looking at comic books and movies in
different ways of helping the visually
impaired really experience life the way
others did I just I'm writing this down
everyone deserves the thrill of being
able to do something that they never
thought was possible I just got
goosebumps when he said that I want to
make sure we keep that and I also like
to what it lovely tribute to Legos we've
done a couple of great little stories
recently remember they they had one
about the ramp the grand
Bravo like a child's toy
yes milds that we all played what I know
and this started because when he was a
kid somebody that knew him well knew
that he wanted and needed that access to
be able to build one set and now Lego
has these sets for everyone as well Dana
I love in your piece when you said I can
see it I could weigh and then you look
and it literally on that Lego set you
see the exact footholds and arm grabs
and that's why I'm like oh wait I'm not
even kidding trying to be nice here
that's really there Thank You Dana